في ادلب منير مصطفى نائب ومدير الدفاع
المدني السوري المدير المصطفى كما تبعت
معنا الرهان وعليكم الان في هذه المرحله
من اجل تقديم المساعدات بعدما توقفت يعني
الامال او تضاءلت الامان في العثور على
ناجين
ما حدود امكانياتكم لمواجهه التحديات التي
تطرحها المرحله الان الحاليه
في الحقيقه فرق الدفاع المدني منذ اللحظه
الاولى لوقوع هذه الكارثه اعلن الاستنفار
الكامل لكافه متطوعي الدفاع المدني الذي
يصل عددهم حتى 3000 متطوع
وانتشرت هؤلاء انتشر هؤلاء المتطوعين مع
الاليات المتاحه مع المعدات المتاحه الى
كافه الاماكن في سباق حقيقي مع الزمن من
اجل انتشال او سحب العالقين وهم على قيد
الحياه من تحت ركام المنازل استطعنا خلال
يعني الايام السابقه من سحب ما يقارب 2950
شخص من تحتها هذه الانقاض وهم على قيد
الحياه وللاسف يعني 24 ساعه الماضيه هي
كانت يعني يعني الخاليه من المنقذين وهم
على قيد الحياه
كلها كانت للاسف هي في جثث يتم سحبها
سحبها من تحت الانقاذ استطعنا الوصول الى
كافه المباني استطعنا ان نقوم بعمليه
البحث بكافه المباني المتضرره
وحقيقه
الامكانيات المتوفره بين يدي عناصر الفاظ
البيضاء وهذه المنظمه هي امكانيات غير
كافيه للتعامل مع حادثه في مثل هذه
الحادثه اطلقنا نداء استغاثه منذ البدايه
لكافه الدول لارسال مساعدات سريعه لتصل
الى فريق القوات البيضاء في شمال غرب
سوريا حتى تساند هذا الفريق من اجل سحب
العالقين وهم على قيد الحياه طبعا اول 72
ساعه هي تعتبر ساعات حاسمه تعتبر ساعات
ذهبيه لفرق الانقاذ في مثل هذه الحوادث
وكنا نامل ان تصل المساعدات في هذا
التوقيت حتى تكون عون لفرقنا والمتطوعيه
الدفاع المدني في اماكن الانهيار على سحب
الناجين وهم على قيد الحياه من تحت
الانقاذ للاسف يعني نحن دخلنا اليوم اليوم
السادس حتى هذه اللحظه لا اليات لا
استجابه على نداء
لا يوجد ارسال للمعدات التقنيه الخاصه
خاصه في انتشار العالقين ونحن دخلنا الان
في المرحله الثانيه وهي مرحله سحب الجثث
من تحت
يعني اكيد تابعت معنا قبل قليل ما قاله
جون كربي مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي ومن
قبل ما قاله ستيفن دجاريك من انه ليس هناك
اي تسييس وان المساعدات ان الانسان هو
الانسان سواء كان في تركيا او في شمال
سوريا اي جهه كان يتبع لها في النهايه كيف
يفسر يعني ما يحدث على الارض في مقابل ما
نسمعه من تصريحات خصوصا ان العالم كله
تعاطف يعني في النهايه رؤيه هذه المناظر
التي شاهدناها كما وانتم بلا شك يعني على
قرب منها شيء يحرك من لا يتحرك
نعم في الحقيقه لا جواب عندي على هذا
السؤال البارحه كان هناك مؤتمر صحفي للسيد
رائد صالح مدير القوات البيضاء الدفاع
المدني طبعا وطلب من خلال هذا المؤتمر
بفتح تحقيق في الامم المتحده
للوقوف على اسباب تاخير وصول المساعدات
الى شمال غرب سوريا هناك جسر جوي كان من
المساعدات باتجاه الدوله التركيه ونسال
الله السلامه لكل عالقين تحت الانقاض ونحن
نشعر بشعور هؤلاء الاشخاص ونشعر بشعور
المنقذين لاننا نحن كما يقولون يدنا في
نفس العمل نحن نقوم بنفس المهام ايضا هناك
ايضا جسر جوي اتجه باتجاه مناطق سيطره
النظام ومساعدات اتت من دول عديده لتصل
وتكون بجانب فرق الانقاذ الموجوده في هذا
المكان الا المنطقه التي هي تقع في شمال
غرب سوريا خارج منطقه النظام ناشدنا منذ
الساعات الاولى ان الكارثه هي اكبر من
استطاعه الخوذ البيضاء واكبر من يعني لا
يملك معدات لتامين كافه الاماكن والوصول
الى كافه الاماكن وحتى هذه اللحظه نحن
دخلنا باليوم السادس لم تاتي يعني اي
معدات لا من الامم المتحده ولا من اي دوله
اخرى طبعا الدول اعربت عن استعدادها
لمساعده القوات البيضاء وهذا شيء مشكور
البارحه بدات تدخل بعض الاغاثات للمنكوبين
من الزلازل دخل من من قطر بعض الامور دخل
من السعوديه بعض الشحنات الاغاثيه وهي
ايضا ضروريه وبشكل كبير ولكن انا اتحدث عن
72 ساعه الاولى التي كانت هي جدا مهمه
لانقاذ حياه والتاخر بارسال المساعدات في
هذه المرحله للاسف ستزيد عدد الضحايا
وسيتحول جزء من هؤلاء الاشخاص العالقين
على وهم على قيد الحياه سيكون في سيكونون
في عداد الاموات للاسف نريد تفصيل اكثر في
مقاله مدير الدفاع المدني امس في لقائمه
الجزيره سيد رائد صالح حينما قال
او التهم الامم المتحده والصليب الاحمر
بتقديم ما وصفه بالمعلومات المضلله بشان
تحركاتهم المتعلقه باغاثه مركوب
فصل لنا اكثر فهذه النقطه بالذات اين كانت
تضليل وما طبيعه التضليل حول ماذا كانت
التضليل بالتحديد
في الحقيقه لم يكن هناك تواصل مباشر مع
فريق القوات البيضاء الذي هو يعتبر الفريق
يعني الوحيد بدعم من المدنيين المتواجد في
مناطق العمل ويعمل على سحب العالقين لم
يكن هناك تواصل مباشر وكان هناك اعلانات
من قبل الامم المتحده انها تقف الى جانب
العالقين او جانب المنكوبين جراء هذا
الزلزال في كل سوريا ولكن للاسف لم نجد اي
يعني وقوف حقيقه حتى مجرد التواصل لم يكن
متواجد اعلان اخر يعني شاهدناه ان فرق
القوه البيضاء لم تصل الا لخمسه بالمئه
في شمال الغرب سوريا ولكن في الحقيقه في
وقت هذا الاعلان كان فريق الفوز البيضاء
استطاع الوصول لما يتجاوز التسعين بالمئه
من هذه الابنيه
لو تعيد هذه النقطه لاننا نسمعك جيدا كان
هناك تقاطع في الصوت النقطه الثانيه
نعم
النقطه الثانيه هي صراحه
الاعلان الذي صدر عن الامم المتحده بان
فريق الاخوه البيضاء لم يصل الا الى 5% من
الابنيه المتضرره حتى تاريخ اللحظه وفي
نفس الوقت كان فريق الفوز البيضاء قد وصل
الى اكثر من 90% من الابنيه المتضرره وقام
بعمليات البحث وسحب العالقين فكان هناك
انفصال كامل عن المعلومات الحقيقيه
المتواجده على الارض من قبل فريق الامم
المتحده وكان هناك تصريحات تاتي يعني من
قبل الامم المتحده بان هناك مسانده بان
هناك مساعده بان هناك معلومات دقيقه هم هي
موجوده عندهم ولكن للاسف هل كان ذلك
المقصودا برايك ام كان فقط لنقص المعطيات
حقيقه يعني ليس لدينا معلومات هل كان
مقصودا ام كان هناك يعني اسباب واسباب
اخرى فلذلك طالب الاستاذ رائد طالب بفتح
تحقيق حقيقي لدى الامم المتحده حتى تتم
متابعه هذه القضايا ولماذا حصلت مثل هذه
الاعلانات ولماذا لم يكن هناك تواصل
ولم يكن هناك اطلاع على ما يحصل في هذه
المنطقه من شمال شمال غرب سوريا بشكل
مباشر لماذا كان هناك اعلانات ان الفريق
الخواز البيضاء وصل الى 5% دون مراجعه
الخوذ البيضاء والتاكد من هذه المعلومه هل
هو فعلا وصل الى 5% وصل الى اكثر ام اقل
ام ام ما هي الاحتياجات الموجوده عند هذا
الفريق صراحه هذا ما طلبنا به فتح تحقيق
حتى نعرف هل هي مقصوده ام هي كانت بسبب
نقص المعلومات المشكله ان المنكوبين على
الارض الان في حاجه للمساعده الحقيقيه
قبل طبعا ان تكون هناك اي تحقيق المهم ان
يصل العون لهم وطبعا كلنا صوت واحد في ان
يحصل ذلك قريبا جدا نشكرك جزيلا منير
مصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني السوري ان
تصل هذه الرسائل الى الجهات المختصه التي
تعنيها طبعا هذا الامر بالتحديد الان نعم
وليس بعد
دقيق الان الان هذا هو